la ley sharia es un conjunto legal
islámico que sirve como código de
conducta ahora bien no todos los países
de la organización mundial de
cooperación islámica que el congo
conglomera digamos a todos los los
estados que adoptan la fe islámica
aplican las leyes charge algunos la
aplican para regular temas eminentemente
familiares
pero el tema es efectivamente más
complejo es la interpretación estricta
que hacen los miembros del talibán
respecto a esta ley islámica y su
extrema imposición sobre efectivamente
las mujeres y especialmente las niñas
menores el panorama es pese a las
palabras de
todo conciliador sigue siendo
preocupante en el país y cuál es ese
panorama qué pasará con las mujeres qué
pasará con la reimposición de la burka
con la educación con la posibilidad de
tener derechos sobre su propio cuerpo
efectivamente esto es lo que se teme es
un retroceso
francamente evidente de las ganancias
que han tenido las mujeres a lo largo de
estos 20 años en los que el talibán no
ha estado al frente del país ya en el
pasado la historia nos enseña cómo fue
el comportamiento del talibán entre 1996
y 2001 prohibir a los teatros prohibían
la educación para las niñas
pequeñas el papel de la mujer en la
sociedad era muy limitado no hay que
olvidar que es la misma organización en
la misma ideología simplemente que el
lado paquistaní que le disparó a la niña
en málaga es el site precisamente cuando
defendía su derecho